hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we are previewing
the Candida sternum at 20:20 my favorite
tournament of the year these players
have been trying to qualify for this
tournament for the past two years it
only comes around every two years the
winner will go on to face Magnus Carlsen
later in the year for the World
Championship we're only a few days away
from the start of this tournament as of
today recording this video the
tournament still on there's not a lot of
other stuff going on right now but the
chess tournament goes on as we know it
so I expect everyone to be watching all
of the chess videos that we put out here
but extremely excited about this field
of eight competitors we're gonna go into
each of the competitors how they
qualified and I'll give some interesting
feedback on each of them just you know
who is gonna be up in this tournament
also let you know who I'm cheering for
who I think will win and then we'll also
get into the structure of the tournament
as well as the schedule so everyone is
prepared for the videos that I will be
putting out but it does start on March
17th these are the eight competitors
will go through one by one the first one
is a Fabiano Caruana he is second ranked
in the world only behind Magnus Carlsen
he won this tournament two years ago
he's representing the United States and
you can see how he qualified was back in
2018 when he won this now when he went
on to face Magnus Carlsen in the World
Championship
they drew every single round so he
didn't lose to Magnus Carlsen in the
standard event now they did go on to
wrap it in blitz and he lost 302 Magnus
Carlsen so that is how he lost but he
tied all 12 games to Magnus Carlsen he's
a phenomenal player definitely has the
best odds to win the tournament and he
will be the player that I will be
cheering for most in this tournament
next competitor is Dean lien he is the
number three ranked player in the world
representing China he qualified by being
a top 2 finisher at the Chess World Cup
last year and this is a player that
really does not lose very often had a
streak of a hundred games from August
2017 although
to November of 2018 remember these top
players they're playing on the biggest
tournaments that's how they're making
their income that's how they're
increasing their rating you're not gonna
be increasing your rating if you're not
playing good opponents so going a
hundred games over a year span is pretty
incredible but in these type of
tournaments the round-robin will get
into the structure here in a little
while it's not just about not losing you
definitely have to be winning a lot of
your games but Delian definitely a
strong competitor in this tournament the
next one is Alexander Bishop he tends to
be at the top of all of these
tournaments he's the fourth ranked
player in the world representing Russia
tournament is being held in Russia
qualification method top two finisher
and the Grand Prix last year he was the
top the next person we'll be looking at
was number two both from Russia but has
had just a hot streak and the last two
Grand Prix's was near the very top if
not winning both of those rounds in the
Grand Prix so he comes in with the
hottest record as of late we'll see if
he can turn that into a victory in at
the candidates tournament right behind
him is young bum vich world ranked
number five he also was a top two
finisher in the Grand Prix right behind
a shook
he's also representing Russia you can
see his rating of 2777 this is my pick
the Dark Horse to win the tournament he
also has one of the best records against
Magnus Carlsen and while I will be
cheering for Fabiana Caruana
last year looking at the 12 games all
draws against Magnus Carlsen I do think
it would be exciting if we had a player
that historically had done extremely
well and that could go toe to toe and
actually put some pressure on Magnus
Carlsen to not just draw it out and then
go into the rapid and blitz games so
definitely it's kind of my second player
that I will be rooting for in the
tournament
next on the list is in VL you can see he
is the 8th ranked player in the world
rating 2767 he's representing France but
his qualification method is a bit
different he
actually replacing a player timur raja
baath who backed out of the tournament
did qualify but decided not to play in
in the tournament nvl he just tried so
long to give this to this tournaments
last time in 2017 at the end of the year
thought he was gonna qualify ended up
not and so did not get to play in the
tournament in 2018 and this year he was
just a tad bit short of making it but
then when Timur backed out he was able
to take his place based on his rating
and when we say rating it's not just at
this time they do look at an extended
period of time and they look at your
rating every single month and they
averaging it out and that is how they
look at the rating which also brings us
to the next player and that is an HD re
he's the world ranked 11th player right
now you can see he had the highest
average rating that didn't qualify but
this is again based on an extended
period of time looking at the average
over months this is the lowest rating
he's had of 27 63 over I think the last
14 or 15 months so he's had a really
strong performance for a very long time
he's representing the Netherlands would
be pretty funny if he won this
tournament just from the banter that you
would see back and forth if anyone
follows him and Magnus Carlsen on
Twitter they usually have some some
pretty funny exchanges back and forth
here this player is tend to be that type
of player that draws a lot he played in
the 2016 candidates tournament and he
drew all 14 games every single game it
was a draw so that's kind of a lot of
the jokes that you'll see online is the
fact that he does a lots of drawls we'll
see what that looks like since not going
to be a lot of handshakes I would
imagine what they do if they want to
draw maybe it's just a head nod maybe
they touch elbows we will see next on
the list we have Wang Hao he's the world
ranked number 12th player in the world
rating 27:58 country China you can see
the qualification method I use the top
finisher in the grand Swiss actually
beat out Fabiano Khan
in magnus carlsen and this is at the end
of last year so although he is only the
12 ranked player in the world he has a
lot of fighting in him he is faced up
you know faced off against some of the
top players in the world and have beaten
them so definitely looking for him to
make a splash here not the most known
player he did say in his latest
interview that he's not friends with
Dingley in which you know you thought
don't have to be from the same country
but it was interesting that he he made
it a point to make sure that people knew
that they were or not close friends and
then lastly we have Khalil he is 39 the
ranked in the world radium 2704 country
Russia qualification method this was a
wild card there's always a wild card
it's generally going to be someone from
the country that's hosting it he is
Russian and so that's why they chose him
he's the youngest player in the field 22
years young very very talented player
you can see not much off the the rating
of some of the other players just does
not have the experience as the rest of
them but definitely expecting a strong
showing from him we'll see if he can
actually compete with the big boys so
let's go ahead and get into this
schedule the tournament starts on the
17th as I mentioned this is a
round-robin tournament which means every
player is going to play everyone else
twice so there's gonna be 14 games
you're gonna play one player with the
white pieces and then eventually you'll
play them with the black pieces they're
gonna play three days in a row and then
they're gonna take a day off they're
gonna play three days and take it off
and they're going to continue that the
time controls if you're looking at the
rules they start with a hundred minutes
that's going to be for the first 40
moves as soon as they cross the 40 move
mark they're gonna get in additional
fifty minutes for the next 20 moves and
then they'll have 15 minutes for the
rest of the game they will be adding on
30 seconds per move but that is the the
time control that we have going on in
the game there are some tie breakers if
we get to that point
I'll I'll make sure I mention those in
the video but my guess is we won't end
up in the tiebreaker we'll see them but
yeah March 17th make sure you mark your
calendars definitely expected everyone
to be watching all of the videos there's
not too many other things that you
should be watching at this time I'm
expecting a very very good tournament
these players if you've listened to the
interviews and if followed them they've
been preparing quite a bit so excited to
see how this ends up thank you guys so
much for watching the prep video
hopefully you're as excited as I am and
I'll see you guys in a couple days for
round one